he you see how I get twisted at the
end yeah I'm a little
twisted that's all that stuff
[Music]
here oh I'm a little twisted so I move
my foot
you have tape on
it oh then it should have tape
okay this this way not this way this
way right cuz if you need to tell me
about an injury he needs to have tape on
it okay you don't need to tell me that's
the only time it doesn't have tap on it
you guys understand that
you heard me tell
exp trying to lower yourself down not
just trying yeah you're trying to
hydraulic your yourself down okay but
what's the why would you do
that okay yeah like let's say the the
the NOG is not slamming you down so you
stay connected so you don't just drop
right but if n is pushing you down
should you be hydraulic in your ass down
no cuz that's going against the energy
that's tell you have to go down okay so
so you all know what I
mean okay this would be me hydraulic
down she's going to slam me down
I have to be SL me
down I have to be able to ride that
down she
determines what rate I go down at not
me now some of you have tight arms and
shoulders still in need of
development you have to move your
BL so when she's tweaking my arm you
might find it better to try and lie this
way you see than doing it this
way so you have to do what it takes to
allow her to do the technique without
you getting
hurt do you understand cuz that's you k
you move where you need to move to not
get hurt okay all right let's look at
the grip here okay see see this grip
here oh these are two
y so I'm using this part of my finger my
hand this knuckle you guys see
it there's one and there's the other
so I'm not this
holding and then leveraging here there's
a leverage in each grip
[Music]
can't be
we fire
so your final positioning it has to do a
lot of things you guys are only doing
some of them it does have to you know
have you have good posture and the
ability to fight the room so you you
remain mobile right you all kind of got
that going but it also makes
you help manipulate the arm with with
your legs okay so when I put her down
here I want this arm to bend like that
right but people don't just do what you
want them to do when you're when you're
fighting them okay you're not going to
just go I'm going to bend my arm so you
can pin it they don't do that so you
have to use your legs to help give you a
mechanical advantage so when you come
around here this
movement is what bends her arm you see
that all right her arms Not Bent so I'm
going to take that
knee and it bends her arm you understand
that okay so there's her arm
straight and I put my knee into
it to get it to roll
over okay see this part that you
normally do e on that's where you put
your
knee right in there it rolls it
down okay
there's where my thumb goes for eel
that's where I'm going to put my
knee not over here
here boom
bow down right here KN to get that to
bend so you get the right
angle on the elbow
now this arm they don't want that there
they want to straighten it out let's say
that's where this foot comes in as I
come to pull the the arm straighten your
arm right straighten your arm can you
see that is it dead
she wants this this foot has to be
here cuz I don't pull this with my
arms you
[Music]
see this fo is here to break